في ايران شعب ونظام تجمعهما الجغرافيا
وتفرغهما سنوات ضوئيه عن الواقع والمستقبل
افيون البعبع الامريكيه الاسرائيلي تلاشى
بعد حكم نصف القرن اثبت فيه النظام فشله
في تامين ادنى متطلبات شعبه وحقوقهم
والدليل كما نرى انتفاضه فقراء صحيفه
جمهور الاسلام تحذر عدوى الوعي انتقلت اذن
من الشعب الى المسؤولين فاخيرا اعترف
احدهم وان بتسجيل صوتيا مسرب بان هذه
الاحتجاجات لم يصممها العدو بل كانت نتيجه
ماسه داخليه ومشاكل اقتصاديه اهم ما في
هذا التسجيل لانه نسب لضابه
نفسي
[موسيقى]
وتبخر 600% من قيمتها وكانها باتت الاسود
عالميا فضلا عن سقوط رموز التكا عليها
النظام لسنوات وهما السببان الرئيسيين
الاحتجاجات
الاعتراف خلف الابواب المغلقه يقابله
انكار وتشويه لحقيقه ما يجري اعلام السلطه
لا ينطق الا عن هواء روايه المرشد وان
تبين انه يمارس هامشا من حريه الانتقاد في
احيان فذلك لان الهامش محسوب وبدقه كتبت
زياره ممثل المرشد لزياره امام محافظه
بلوشستان التي لم تكن لتحصل لو لم يشعر
خامنئي بان سيناري تقسيم البلاد سيتحقق
ولابد من فتره احتواء انا ابعد عقود من
تزايد البطش والتمييز والحرمان بحق اهل
البروستاتان